it's taken more than a week for these
images to reach the outside world
covered in dust clearly in shock but at
first confirmation some civilians
survived the bombing of a theater in
mariopol
eyewitnesses say at least 300 people
lost their lives it's not clear how many
more may still be buried here
the building had been packed with more
than a thousand civilians the word
children clearly visible from the air
diana lived next to the theater but
escaped before the bombing
everywhere it was flooded with people i
know that there were pregnant women that
were brought from that maternity ward in
the third house hospital that was bombed
the days before they were brought to the
theater because it's like a big building
they put these women uh with kids or
pregnant women in these dressing rooms
for for the actors
and it was in this this part which was
born and they were in the theater when
it was yeah they were in the 30th they
were right in on the
exactly like the point where it was hit
diana says there are now so many bodies
they're not buried anymore and body
parts hang from trees
those who are still living this
nightmare have little way of being heard
british photographer max clark recently
escaped with these images and stories of
suffering the bodies are largely being
buried by now but there's still some you
can certainly smell them in piles of
rubble that are inaccessible
there are dogs feeding on chunks of bone
human bone
bits of people
there are freshly dug graves everywhere
their cries for help cannot be heard but
the people of mariopol need saving from
this living hell
sally lockwood sky news la viv in
western ukraine